Getting fat after you have a baby.
Bear with me,
because I'm not about to say what you think I'm about to say.
If you are someone who is overweight or not
where you metabolically wanna be,
and you haven't had a baby
or you're planning on having a baby,
and you are scared.
You are terrified that you're just going to get worse
from the state that you are now
to after you have the baby and postpartum,
and you're gonna be one of those that never loses the baby weight.
Listen to what I have to say.
I have not always been as thin as I am right now.
In fact, for years,
I was always a little bit on the curvier side,
and I was very gachatona, meaning,
like, my face.
Gachatona is like, your face was chunky or chubby,
but it also adds, like,
a youthful appearance, right?
I suffer with PCOS and endometriosis,
inflammatory issues, chronic illness,
autoimmune, my entire life.
And I just didn't really connect the dots until I was older.
But I was always terrified.
I mean, freaking terrified.
After I had a baby,
I would be one of those that blew up like a freaking balloon
and never was able to lose the weight,
because that, quite frankly,
had been my history since I was about 17 years old.
But I desperately wanna offer you some encouragement, okay?
Because I had a baby. I've had two babies,
and each one I Have lost more and more weight,
have gotten more and more healthy now.
Yes, there are things that I am doing that are aiding that journey
in getting healthier and losing weight
and being metabolically healthy.
But I can tell you right now
with all of my chronic feminine issues, endometriosis,
PCOS, all the things.
For years when I went to go see my doctor,
their solution to everything was always, well,
you need to just have a baby.
You need to have a baby. I remember taking my ex
and he went to one of my appointments with me
and feel like she kind of pressured him
cause she was like, well,
she's 28 years old, 29 years old,
she needs to have a baby. And all these issues will go away.
there's a lot of truth behind that and a lot of scientific evidence.
But what I want to tell you,
as far as the weight is concerned
and the metabolic issues are concerned,
when I had a baby, I mean,
it completely reset my entire system.
It reset my hormones, my fat distribution, everything.
Now here's the science. Uh,
scientifically,
we're actually most capable of carrying a child at around age 17.
That is scientifically
the age where we are supposed to be already bearing children.
Now, as much as the feminist wanna be like,
I'm more than having babies.
Of course you are. There's other things that you can do in life, okay?
And that You have value add in this world,
but at the end of the day,
we are animals and we are biological,
and biologically, we were created to create.
With that said,
most women are not having babies until they're mid to late 30s now,
especially with modern feminism or culture.
Just everything from 17 years old to your mid 30s,
end of your 30s, you're talking 15,
20 years, two decades of not having a baby,
when biologically,
your prime time to have a baby was about 17 years old.
And again, you already know how I feel about having babies young.
Um, I feel like we've been fed this really big lie
that it's the end of the world,
we get pregnant, that nothing can ever, um,
good come in our lives, that our careers are dead,
which doesn't even make even a little bit of sense,
especially considering our fertile windows this big.
And I work in financial retirement advising,
and your time for retirement and building a career is this big.
Anyway, I digress.
But you are talking two decades
of something that's not happening to your body,
that your body is expecting or somewhat wanting.
Now, again,
there is. Sorry,
cut me off. Now, again,
there is more scientific, um,
reasoning to this for what I'm saying. Okay,
more scientific verbiage and everything
that makes a little bit more sense.
But basically, your body wanted to have a baby starting at 17,
but now you're 35, And you still haven't had a baby,
but you're considering have a baby.
That's where we're at. There is a huge chance,
a huge possibility
that by the time you have a baby,
your body will completely reset itself.
The reason we are having all this inflammation and endometriosis,
which is excessive lining on your uterus.
Aside from environmental toxins,
birth control, all that stuff,
at the end of the day, a lot of it is just the fact
that your body hasn't done what it wants to do.
The uterine lining, that was excessively growing tissue,
which is endometriosis, that completely went away
or just got real mild compared to the way it was before.
And even my mom said when she was having babies that with each baby,
it just got better and better and easier and easier,
as far as her body was concerned.
But again, we are having babies so much later. Anyway,
my whole point to this is,
if you are so terrified
that you are going to gain an excessive amount of weight
while you're pregnant, or if you are even then.
I gained a lot of weight, okay?
I'm a big bird. I'm 5:11, okay?
So I think my first son, I got up to 2:50.
Like, you couldn't tell because I'm so tall.
And I carried it well, but I was freaking heavy.
I could feel it on my joints, everything.
But my point is, even with the excessive weight gain,
that I had. Carrying each child,
I dropped the weight and even more,
I am lighter now than I was in high school. Okay.
We are fed so much misinformation
and we are fed so much fear mongering
that one having a baby just sounds terrifying in itself.
Because everyone has their opinion that degrades motherhood,
when in reality,
those opinions should be redirected towards our culture
and our family lives. Um,
because it's just. It's garbage.
Um, it shouldn't be directed towards motherhood itself,
but I just remember how scared I was when I was pregnant
because I thought, you know,
I've always had a hard time losing weight.
It's never gonna happen. No diet ever worked.
Nothing ever worked. Like,
I'm gonna have a baby, and I'm just gonna get bigger and bigger,
and it is just gonna be detrimental to my self confidence,
my ego, my health,
everything. And that's not what happened, babe.
Like, the weight fell off.
And I don't mean this in a derogatory way whatsoever,
but, like,
when you have a baby,
if you really are putting your full effort to being,
you know, using that as your job,
like, your job is to take this tiny
little human being through your fourth trimester
and make it have a secure attachment
and make it grow independent
and make it feel loved and healthy and valued.
If you're pouring everything into that child,
it's almost impossible to keep the weight on.
Like I was breastfeeding I was taking walks,
we were playing outside, I was doing activities.
Of course, you lose a little bit of sleep and, like,
you were always going like the freaking Energizer Bunny.
Okay. And I don't even know when it happened,
but I looked in the mirror and I was like,
oh, my god.
I don't even remember ever looking like this.
Maybe when I was, like, 15.
And even then I was a little more catchy. Donna.
So don't be scared. Because sometimes
we just have to trust the process and the cycles of our body,
especially in our fertile years.
Because as much as we don't wanna think
that our entire identity is tied up into being a mother, biologically,
sometimes it is.
And I'm speaking from experience and talking with my doctors.
I know that a lot of this is scientific, um,
scientifically founded, but it just reset everything.
So don't worry, don't stress.
And at the end of the day,
even if you do gain weight and it's hard to lose,
there are so many things that you can do
to get your body to bounce back and be healthy.
I'm not talking about weight loss.
I'm talking about just being healthy and being the best you you can be
so that you can be the best mom to your children,
best wife to your husband,
whatever. Whatever it is that you wanna be good at,
you can be that. It's not the end of the World,
once you have a baby, and I promise you,
like, I know very few women that actually didn't bounce back.
And a lot of the time, it's just.
It's our modern society. It is our toxic suit we're wearing every day.
It's our modern medicine.
But if you really fall into the ebbs and flows of motherhood,
you're going to find it just flows like it's.
It's gonna come off you. Anyway,
that is my rant for tonight.
My god, I'm sorry.
It went on for nine minutes. Love you.